hi
um i've received hate online
a lot of it and it comes with the
territory of my work
i'm a digital creator i make things
specifically for the internet
like a few years ago i made a video
series called every single word where i
edited down popular films to only the
words spoken by people of color
as a way to empirically and accessibly
talk about the issue of representation
in hollywood
then later as transphobic bathroom bills
started gaining media attention around
the united states
i hosted and produced an interview
series called sitting in bathrooms with
trans people
where i did exactly that and then
sure i'll take applause
thank you um and then are you familiar
with those
unboxing videos on youtube where
youtubers open up the latest
electronic gadgets great so i satirized
those in a weekly series where instead i
unboxed
intangible ideologies like police
brutality
masculinity and the mistreatment of
native americans
um my work thanks one person applauding
god bless
um mom hi
um so my work
became popular very popular i got
millions of views a ton of great press
and a slew of new followers
but the flip side of success on the
internet
is internet hate um i was called
everything
from beta to snowflake and of course the
ever-popular
cuck don't worry i will break these
terms down for you
so beta for those of you unfamiliar is
shorthand
online lingo for beta mail but let's be
real i wear pearl earrings and my
fashion aesthetic is rich white woman
running errands
so i'm not angling to be an alpha
doesn't totally work
now snowflake is a put down for people
who are sensitive
and believe themselves to be unique and
i'm a millennial and an
only child so duh
[Laughter]
but my favorite favorite favorite is
cuck it's a slur short for cuckold
for men who have been cheated on by
their wives but
friends i am so gay that if i had a wife
i would
encourage her to cheat on me
thank you let's take a look at some of
this
negativity in action um sometimes it's
direct
like marcos who wrote you're everything
i hate in a human being
thank you marcos others are more concise
like donovan who wrote gaywad
now i do need to point out donovan is
not
wrong okay in fact he's right on both
counts so credit where credit is due
thank you donovan others write to me
with questions like brian who asked were
you born a or did you just learn
to be one over time
but my favorite thing about this is that
once brian was done typing his finger
must have slipped because then he sent
me
the thumbs up emoji so babe
thumbs up to you too um
uh it's fun to talk about these messages
now
right and it's cathartic to laugh at
them
but i can tell you that it really does
not feel good
to receive them uh at first
i would screenshot their comments and
make fun of their typos but this
soon felt elitist and ultimately
unhelpful
so over time i developed an unexpected
coping mechanism
because most of these messages i
received were through social media i
could often click
on the profile picture of the person who
sent them and learn
everything about them i could see
pictures they were tagged in
posts they'd written memes they'd shared
and somehow seeing that it was a human
on the other side of the screen
made me feel a little better not to
justify what they wrote
right but just to provide context
still that didn't feel like enough
so i called some of them only the ones i
felt safe talking
to with a simple opening question
why did you write that the first person
i spoke to was josh
he had written to tell me that i was a
i was a reason this country was
dividing itself
and he added at the end that being gay
was a sin
i was so nervous for our first
conversation
this wasn't a comment section so i
couldn't use tools
like muting or blocking of course i
guess um
i could have hung up on him but i didn't
want to
because i liked talking to him because i
liked him
here's a clip of one of our
conversations
josh you said that you're about to
graduate high school
right how is high school for you
am i allowed to use the h e double
hockey stick word oh yeah you're allowed
to
it was hell really and it's still hell
right now even though it's only two
weeks left
i'm a little bit bigger i don't like to
use the word fat but i am a little bit
bigger than a lot of my classmates and
they seem to judge me before they even
got to know me
that's awful i mean i also just want to
let you know josh
i was bullied in high school too
so did our common ground of being
bullied in high school erase what he
wrote me
no and did our single phone conversation
radically heal a politically divided
country and cure systemic injustice
no absolutely not right
but did our conversation humanize us to
each other more than profile pictures
and posts
ever could absolutely i didn't stop
there
because some of the hate i received was
from my
side so when matthew a queer
liberal artist like me publicly wrote
that i
represented some of the worst aspects of
liberalism
i wanted to ask him this you tagged me
in this post
did you want me to see it i honestly
didn't think that you would
have you ever been publicly dragged
i have been and i just said no i don't
care
and did you know it was hard did you not
care um
oh well i cared yes
at the end of these conversations
there's often a moment of reflection
a reconsideration and that's exactly
what happened
at the end of my call with a guy named
doug who had written that i was a
talentless propaganda hack
did the conversation we just had does it
like make you feel differently about how
you write online
yeah you know when i said this to you
when i said you were timeless hacked i'd
never converse with you in my life
really i didn't really
know anything really about you and i
think that a lot of times that's what
the comment sections really are
it's really a way to get your anger
at the world out on random profiles of
strangers pretty much
yeah um right but it definitely has made
me
rethink the way that i
interact with people online
so i've collected these conversations
and many others from my podcast
conversations with people who hate me
um before i started this project i
thought that the real way to bring about
change was to shut down opposing
viewpoints
through epically worded video essays and
comments and posts but i soon learned
those were only cheered on by the people
who already agreed with me
sometimes bless you sometimes the most
subversive thing you could do
yeah clap for him
um sometimes the most subversive thing
you could do
was to actually speak with the people
you disagreed with and not simply at
them
now in every one of my calls i always
ask my guests to tell me about
themselves
and it's their answer to this question
that allows me
to empathize with them and empathy it
turns out is a key
ingredient in getting these
conversations off the ground but it can
feel
very vulnerable to be empathizing with
someone you profoundly disagree with
so i established a helpful mantra for
myself
empathy is not endorsement
empathizing with someone you profoundly
disagree with does not
suddenly compromise your own deeply held
beliefs and endorse
theirs empathizing with someone who for
example believes that being gay is a sin
doesn't mean that i'm suddenly going to
drop everything pack my bags and grab my
one-way ticket to hell right
it just means that i'm acknowledging the
humanity of someone who is raised to
think very differently from me
i also want to be super clear about
something this is not
a prescription for activism right i
understand
that some people don't feel safe talking
to their detractors and others feel so
marginalized
that they justifiably don't feel that
they have any empathy to give
i totally get that this is just what i
feel well suited to do
you know i've reached out to a lot of
people for this podcast and
some have politely declined others have
read my message and ignored it some have
blocked me automatically when i sent the
invitation
and one guy actually agreed to do it and
then five minutes into the call
hung up on me i'm also aware that this
talk
will appear on the internet and with the
internet comes comment sections and with
comment sections inevitably
comes hate so as you are watching this
talk
you can feel free to call me whatever
you'd like you can call me a gaywad
a snowflake a cuck a beta
or everything wrong with liberalism but
just know
that if you do i may ask you to talk
and if you refuse or block me
automatically
or agree and hang up on me then maybe
babe
the snowflake is you thank you so much
thank you